comenzamos directo a la sección en la
que hablamos con nuestra red de
corresponsales hoy nos quedamos aquí en
bogotá con nuestro periodista luís muñoz
y es que se cumpla el primer aniversario
del paro nacional en colombia las
movilizaciones que comenzaron para
oponerse a la reforma tributaria
terminaron en un rechazo masivo a varias
de las políticas del gobierno de iván
duque las manifestaciones se prolongaron
durante días y en los choques con la
policía hubo entre 40 y 80 muertos
dependiendo de quién de las cifras y la
fiscalía o diferentes ongs entonces le
damos la bienvenida a lluís tú ves como
estás muy bien muy muy contenta estar
aquí contigo maria clara bueno yo
también se ubicó trata de estar contigo
y vamos a poner en contexto a nuestros
televidentes porque usted viajó a cali
una de las ciudades que fue el epicentro
de las protestas y hoy es explíquenos
que pasó allí y en general que ocurrió
durante el paro nacional de hace un año
como bien has comentado sí que se cumple
un año de paro nacional hoy y es que hay
que ver que durante el día ha habido
distintas
conmemoraciones más que
eventos combativos como se dieron lugar
el año pasado y por eso vamos a hacer un
poco de contexto con el pasado año y es
que hace un año el 28 de abril de 2021
el gobierno de iván duque pretendía
pasar una reforma tributaria una reforma
que era más regresiva que progresiva y
que afectaba sobre todo a las clases
bajas ya las medias más caras altas
estas clases además estaban más
castigadas por la pandemia del cob y 19
que como recordemos en 2020 colombia
llegó a la pobreza a un 42 por ciento
pobreza que descendió en 2021 hasta el
39 por ciento y es que cuando empezó ese
28 de abril sí que se vieron pues esas
protestas contra la reforma tributaria
pero poco a poco fueron apareciendo pues
más protestas contra otro tipo de cosas
estructurales no como la falta de acceso
al empleo también a la salud también a
la vivienda y también el recrudecimiento
del conflicto durante en todo el
territorio colombiano como el asesinato
de líderes sociales protestas que
convocaron masivas protestas miles de
personas también
hundimos cortes de vías también vimos
cómo quedaban ciudades aisladas del
resto del país de cali y finalmente pues
vamos a hacer un balance de los daños
que se hicieron en esos abusos que
también se denunciaron contra la policía
de los derechos humanos también la
violencia policial vamos a hacer un
resumen a una tabla de datos que podemos
ver ahí que es del informe grita de la
ong tambores pero también del programa
de acción por la igualdad y la inclusión
social de la universidad de los andes y
del ministerio de defensa
destacan ahí esos más de 14.000
concentraciones masivas durante todo el
país desde abril hasta julio también ahí
vemos más de 5000 casos de violencia
detenidos unas cifras que la verdad que
conmocionaron tanto al país como a la
opinión pública internacional
también cabe destacar que en nuestro
equipo como bien has dicho estuvimos en
cali también hubo la verdad es que el el
paro nacional se extendió por todo el
conflicto pero en cali sobre todo vimos
como fue el epicentro
representa un poco a lo que es
colombiano con grandes desigualdades
sociales con edificios de lujo muy cerca
también de laderas humildes también una
ruta del narcotráfico hacia el océano
pacifico y también una zona donde se han
visto muchos civiles armados como se
vieron aquellos días yo sí le quiero
preguntar si se han cumplido las
exigencias de los manifestantes y sobre
todo que le espera a estas demandas de
cara al cambio de presidente pues en
colombia habrá elecciones el próximo 29
de mayo se considera que está un poco en
standby esa protesta y es que no se han
acabado de responder a las quejas
estructurales que hemos visto antes y de
hecho la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos emitió 41
recomendaciones que los analistas creen
que nos han cumplido y que pueden hacer
que para el próxima legislatura cuando
haya nuevo presidente puedan volver a
ver nuevas protestas y es que las
naciones habían pedido que también se
avance en las investigaciones y en el
esclarecimiento de lo que pasó aquellos
días y veremos si en las elecciones
gustavo petro el cambio de la izquierda
es la alternativa que pueda dar
respuesta a estos daños estructurales si
el candidato de derecha pico gutiérrez
para hacer un continuismo con sergio
fajardo gastado como respondiendo en sus
misiones a estos daños sociales puede
hacer algo muchas gracias maneras ya
logremos lluís y muchas gracias a
ustedes ahora sigamos con deportes